hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show we're outside the
studio with filmmaker ty West incredible
interview thanks thanks madam um were
curious how important has it been for
you to continue on to your next project
rather than pushing and promoting your
previous one um very you know I think
for me like the pushing of ammonia is
really enjoyable and been very fun but
then you start seeing other people you
don't make other movies I think we
talked about this in there and that for
me it's really hard because I you know I
prolific people with the rotation
interested in me that's why I mentioned
that Stephen King book is the reason I
found it it's not just because I like
horror movies and I like receiving king
it's because Stephen King's one of the
most prolific successful offers ever so
it's just like how does he pull house
you write bestseller books every year
that's crazy and that's why I look for
stuff like that so for me it's just you
know it's a lifestyle more than a career
and it's very important to me to keep
working and I'm only I only feel
fulfilled when I'm making a movie even
though while iming and I hate it but
it's always way life it's a weird
process so for me promoting it can only
last so long before you start to feel
like you're getting behind so I think
it's important to keep going so it's
almost a thrill of the hunt in some
sense for you that's what challenges you
kind of yeah I mean I just I making
movie something or they know how to do
and it's only thing I really kind of
want to be doing so and the experience
is such a in life and I get to go to
weird places and make movies is it but
unique experiences and I like that
otherwise I'm just like sitting at home
panicking so for me it's just a
termination to kind of stay out there I
mean promoting it is great because you
feel good about yourself for a little
bit but I get I started like you know I
start to worry that I'm i'm resting too
much and get out there so I'd like to
make a movie like Woody Allen has the
amazing career making movie every year
that's what I'd like to do and do you
have a question for our audience
do a question of the day we put it on
our Facebook do you have anything for
the filmmakers out there something to
kind of get their minds spinning a
little bit I don't know how exactly for
the filmmakers i would say for audiences
listens to a show like this you know
maybe it's beneficial for everyone
different for them to think about like
what do they want out of a show like
this like what would be when you two
need to listen to it is it like anecdote
see listening for or is it like some
sort of advice that's going to change
everything I don't know the answer but
maybe that's something that's kind of
you know yeah valuable was to figure out
what it is that you want from sure like
this the show about for me
Oh